てゅーる↑るてゅーてゅっ↓
ひゅぅ～↑～↓～↑～↓てゅぅるるる～
ピイイイイイイイイイイイ!!!!!!!
………
スチャッ！
～はじめの舞～
（♪ 海は広いな大きいな～）
はじめしゃちょー2016年
最後の質問コーナー
（笛でトリル）
大変お待たせしました
あの、、Twitterで募集したら
なんなんすかね、Twitterの方が気楽にかけるのかな
YouTubeのコメントよりすごい多かった気がしました
そしてこの動画が僕の今年最後の動画になります
もう2016年最後の質問コーナーはとりあえずスピード感
もうスピード感しかないからね　　　　（ブウウウウウウン）
ノンストップで
皆の質問、リクエスト答えてくぜ！
ではいこーー！！
ん？
ママじゃないよ
カレーじゃないよ
あ？
うい
うん
わかった
やれって言われたからにはやりますよ
履きます
もう無理！
俺の”俺”が
はい
はい　　お
おえぇぇぇｌ
100分後は05時06分
絶対微妙だ
いただきます
うまっ！
多分なんですけど、僕は面白くなくなったらやめます
すぐに。
ちゃっちゃーいw
ぅあーー花丸ちゃんかヨハネで迷ったんですけども
多分ヨハネです
堕天使！
ありがとうございます
はい
高校生くらいからめちゃくちゃ乾燥肌で
冬とかなにもしなかったら皮がぼろぼろ剥けてくるんですよ
なんで確か二十歳ぐらいになってからずっと化粧水と乳液
→をずっと使ってます
ほんと男の子も絶対やった方がいいです
あとは
お菓子食べないことかな
（キラリ～ン）
うわーーー難しいっすね
僕は個人的にその異性の友達と言える友達がいないので
女の子に親友がいるっていう感覚がわかんないです
親友に恋してるっていう時点でもう親友じゃない気もしちゃいますねぇ
恋しちゃった時点でもう友達にはなれないと僕は思っちゃいます…
好きなら好きで気持ち伝えようや
*大爆笑中*
今年のアニメで言ったら”響け！ユーフォニアム2"の2期がすごい泣けました
こっそり見てました
吹奏楽のアニメなんですけども
部活一生懸命頑張ったことある人達が見ると
多分すげー感動すると思います
是非見てみてください
何言うとんねん
食べません
（前方倒立回転とび）
いいでしょう
やべぇ
俺が質問を募集する動画で半分冗談で
にんじん3本食べてぇ
って呟いたら
めちゃくちゃ大勢の人が
「にんじん3本食べてぇ」って書いてしまった
これは
どうしよう
もう食べるしかないのか
にんじん3本
食べま
せん！！！！！
高橋先生、ご結婚おめでとうございます
誰ですか？
人見知りって
そういうもんやで
何言っとんねん
これは多分君のやりたいことに対する熱量によってだと思います
なんとなくやってみたいなーみたいな感じだったら多分大学に行った方が良い
高校卒業して就職したり専門学校に行っちゃうと
基本的にはその道のレールに乗ってしまいます
戻ったりすることはできるんですけど
なんとなーくやりたいなって思ってるんだったら
大学に入ってたくさん時間ができると思うので
その4年間の中で本当にそれがやりたいのかどうかっていうことを自分に聞いてみたり
他に好きなことができるかもしれないんで
君のやりたいことに対する熱量次第なんですけども
大学に入って4年間色んなこと学んで考えるのもありかなと思います
良い人生を
おえぇえぇ
ウィルキンソンを振って逆さに開けると
なんと
勢いよくこぼれます
大好きです
君は何を求めてるんだ
良いと思うよ
おえぇぇ
これは簡単だねー
真ん中でしょー？
おぉぉい！
良い奴やないかい
あっ
意外と！
意外とぉ！
結構鼻水出るな
やばい人だああああ
虎之助...
お前は一発屋だ
大丈夫か¿¿
お前は...
いつしかの俺の母ちゃんの偽アカウント
帰れ！
ドラァ！
はじめ：もしもし？
親　分：もしもし？
はじめ：あっ、HIKAKIN?
親分：うぇ？？wwwww
はじめ：ｱｲHIKAKIN元気か？
はじめ：HIKAKIN、今年もありがとね
親　分：おーーありがとな
はじめ：HIKAKIN、来年もよろしく頼むわー
親分：来年も頼むわなーこちらこそな
すいませんでしたぁぁぁ
親分：ウフフフフフフw
なんかポケモンGO始まってからすごいポッポに似てるって言われるんですけど
そんな似てますか？
言われてみれば...
違います
うわああああふぅうう
そのギャップも素晴らしい！！！だからはじめしゃちょー！ぜひぜひアノマロカリス大好きになってください
お願いします！
はい
ありがとう
頑張るよ
その顔は一体なんだい？
今年の質問コーナーは結構角やタンスに小指をぶつけることが多かったが
もうなんかこれもうなんかレギュラー化してきてしまっている
やべぇ、色んな人が「小指ぶけつけろ」って言ってくる
うぅぅ痛いからまじでぶつけたくない
前回多分骨イってた説があるんだ
誰だこれは
小指をいたわってくれてる人がいる
皆ありがとう
小指をいたわってくれるてる人がいる
俺は
俺はもう！ぶつけません！
I have a 角
I have a 小指
うああああああああああ
痛い痛いいててててて
ほんとに痛いほんとに痛いほんとに痛い
あの
来年は
何があってもしません
あの、、色々あったけど楽しい1年でした
是非来年も
暇な時になんとなく暇つぶしで見れるような動画をぽぽっと出していこうと思います
是非来年もはじめしゃちょーよろしくお願いします
では良いお年を
じゃあな！